et même si le suspect se trouve derrière
les barreaux maintenant les familles des
trois policiers tombés sous les balles
de justin bourg sont encore bouleversés
la famille de d'evra ans originaire de
victoriaville au québec s'est adressé au
midi alors que les proches des deux
autres victimes ont décidé de vivre leur
deuil en privé
rebecca martel 3 chandelle pour trois
hommes qui ont payé de leur vie pour
faire régner l'ordre devant leurs
sacrifices et les efforts sans relâche
de la grc les gens apportent des fleurs
le jeune william à une rose rouge pour
dave ross pour tabriz gevaudan et pour
double slash
les policiers de la grc pour les
remercier pour le travail qui fais pour
nous qui sont abattus de façon sensible
on essaye de trouver une raison puis on
n'est pas capable ma mère travaille ici
la lipo policière met à travailler ici
alors ça nous touche pas mal proche là à
32 ans d'evra c'était le plus jeune des
trois il laisse dans le deuil sa
conjointe leurs jeunes de 18 mois et un
bébé qui doit naître en septembre sa
famille à partager
l'homme qu'il était même si tu as tout
en optimisant consterné il s'avère m'ont
tellement c'est un relief mais c'est
comme ça il dressa d'achat compagnie
une telle échelle des nations can et
agen et à notre héroïne dont il ya une
abeille sur des personnes metting ymagis
d'arrivée même politique
j'ai deux surtout pu s'effectuer je sois
qui est très je suis n'y a pas eu de
tels fichiers a formé à 40 en dehors de
cela j'avais eu toutes sortes d'emplois
mais ils avaient enfin réaliser son rêve
de devenir policier père de trois filles
il aimait particulièrement les voir
danser ses filles fréquentent l'école le
sommet c'est donc toute une communauté
qui est en deuil
pour les gens du comité de parents la
nouvelle est difficile à accepter
je vous quitte ea à décrire comment je
me ressens une certaine tristesse
incroyable je peux pas imaginer ce
qu'elle a pu ressentir je peux je peux
pas imaginer ce que ces enfants peuvent
ressentir perdre par an c'est le pire
cauchemar d'un enfant puis elle en a
trois je souhaite beaucoup de courage
fabrice gevaudan venaient de france mais
à 45 ans sa vie et est maintenant au
canada
il laisse dans le deuil sa conjointe et
une fille de 10 ans dans son quartier
les gens d'apprécier
fabrice est un gentil monsieur toujours
très sympathique qui on y pense et c'est
toujours un gros lots était très fière
de son sol un script insee il peut
parler de quoi il était vraiment gentil
on note records vraiment sain
aujourd'hui pour pour sa famille
trois hommes ont passé bien différent
unis dans un destin tragique leurs
proches la grande famille de la grc et
tous les gens de moncton n'oublierons
jamais ce qu'ils ont fait ici rebecca
martel radio-canada monteux